Baby puffins are called "Pufflings".
11 of the 12 men to have walked on the Moon
were in the Boy Scouts.
Every month in the Netherlands, 133 billion
insects are killed colliding into cars.
Squirrels can remember the hiding places of
up to 10,000 nuts.
In 2011, cheese was the most stolen food in
the world.
During pregnancy, some women crave non-edible
items, such as paper, clay and metal, it's
an eating disorder known as Pica.
A man from Florida was arrested after calling
911 three times asking the dispatcher if she
was interested in going on a date with him.
Gladiator sweat was used as a beauty product
for one's skin in Ancient Rome.
The expiration date on bottled water is actually
for the bottle, not the water.
The most times a person has been stung by
bees without dying is 2,443.
Dogs can smell where electric current has
been and human fingerprints that are a week
old.
Under the provisions of the 1912 Scottish
Protection of Animals Act, the Loch Ness monster
is a protected species.
The lion used in the original MGM movie logo
killed its trainer and two assistants the
day after the logo sequence was filmed.
California consumes more bottled water than
any other product.
Spiders are extremely carnivorous.
10,000 spiders sealed in a room will eventually
result in one enormously fat spider.
Lava can flow as fast as a sprinting greyhound.